[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلها بابره
العربي
واشنطن يعيد التصعيد ضد حكومه الدبابه
البرلمان يصف الخطوه بالخيانه
مع بدل اعتماد الاعدامات الامم المتحده
تحذر من ان حياه المحتاجين في خطر وعقوبات
اوروبيه تطال مسؤولين وكيانات ايرانيات
فرنسيه سابقه للعربيه نظام الاسد متورط
باغتيال الحريري والمحكمه الدوليه بدلت
قرارها تحت الضغط
بشعار مشابه وعلامتين زرقاوين بدل واحده
منصه تمبلر تسخر من تويتر وتستقبل
المهاجرين منها
[موسيقى]
تتفاعلوا قضيه تسليم ابو عجيله مسعود بشكل
كبير في ليبيا لبى قد تسببت بازمه سياسيه
داخليه
لبيبه بالوقوف وراء تسليم ابو عشيله
لواشنطن وبتهمه الخيانه العظمى للبلاد
تعهد البرلمان الليبي بمحاكمه كل من تورط
من الليبيين في اعاده فتح ملف البيت وفي
سياق نفسه قال مسؤولون امريكيون من مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي انه ابو عجيله اعترف
بانه جمله صدر باوامر مباشره من المخابرات
الليبيه وانا القذافي شاكره واخرين بعد
الهجوم هذا ومن المتوقع ان يمثل ابو عجيل
امام محكمه اتحاديه في واشنطن في هذه
اللحظات
[موسيقى]
ملاحظه اكثر من ثلاثه عقود انتهت بوقوع
المتهم بصناعه قنبله تفجير اللقب بعجين
مسعود المريمي اعتقاله مثل خطوه مهمه في
تحقيق مستمر منذ عقود لكنه شكل لغز كبيره
فكيف وقع المطلوب الليبيه
[موسيقى]
عام 2018
بعض سقوط النظام القذافي عام 2011 تم
اعتقاله من قبل السلطات انفاذ القانون
الليبيه
[موسيقى]
اعتقال تحقيقات انتهت بتلقي المسؤولين
الامريكيين نسخه عن مقابله اجرتها السلطات
الليبيه معجبه كشافه اعتراضات له عن تصنيع
القنبله المستخدمه
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
[موسيقى]
بعد اعوام قليله اعاده الولايات المتحده
لفتح ملف اللقبي عبر توجيه التهامات رسميه
لبرجيله تتعلق بالارهاب الى انه ظل موجود
في الاراضي الليبيه مع تعاهد المسؤولين
الامريكيين والاسكتلنديين بالعمل على
تسريبه حتى يمكن محاكمته فعليه
[موسيقى]
بعد عمليه لوثير الجدل مجددا بعد ان اصدرت
عائلته بيانات في نوفمبر الماضي تلتهم فيه
جهات المحليه باختطاف
نوفمبر 16 نوفمبر الماضي
من بيته متاخر من الليل
المشتركه في المدينه
وبنته وزوجته
[موسيقى]
طلعت المصدي عليكم
لكنها لم تعلن حتى الان كيف وصل القبضتها
حسين يعني اليوم
السؤال الذي يطرحه الليبيون على اي اساس
سيحاكم ابو عشيله اليوم خصوصا ان يعتبر
الملف قد اقفل في العام 2008
تحيه لك ليال بالفعل هذا هو السؤال الاهم
الان ودعيني فقط اخبرك باني انا اقف امام
المحكمه الفيدراليه هنا في العاصمه واشنطن
حيث يوجد ابو عجيله بالنسبه لعلى اي اساس
ضحايا العائلات عائلات لوربي بعد الاعلان
عن وجود ابو عجيله هنا اعرضوا عن ارتياحهم
فالامريكيون حتى السلطات الامريكيه اعلنت
سابقا بانها تسعى لمواصله محاكمه همم
المسؤولين عن تفجير به من اجل تحقيق
العداله لهؤلاء الضحايا واليسرهم الموضوع
بالنسبه للامريكيين لم ينتهي رغما ان
الرئيس الاسبق جورج دبليو بوشكانا اصدر
مرسوما اكد فيه التزام بلاده بانها لن
يكون هناك محاكمات همم اخرى
قبل ان تكمل ابو عجيله موجود الان داخل
المحكمه وهل بدات المحاكمه
من المفروض الان حسب ما علمنا بان هو
موجود الان وحتى نرى الان على العديد من
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه هنا متواجده في
هذا في عين المكان
لمتابعه الموضوع من ننتظر ان تبدا
المحاكمه وتبدا الاستعجبات في هذه اوقات
ربما بدات ولكن لم يعلن عنها بشكل رسمي
حتى الان ولكنه موجود في هذه المحكمه حسب
ما عرفنا ليال
بالمناسبه هي هنا في وسط العاصمه مباشره
حسين هناك من وسط العاصمه واشنطن ما
المتوقع بهذه المحاكمه هل من تسريبات
للصحفيين هل من معلومات خصوصا ان يعني
المعلومات الرسميه منذ ان تم تسليمه الى
واشنطن حتى الساعه
بالفعل لا يهال هذا من نسعى للحصول عليه
الامريكان حتى الان يلتزم رسميا يلتزمون
الصمت نحن استمعنا الى عدد من اسر الضحايا
سمعهم يتكلمون يقولون انهم ساعه بهذا
الاعتقال بانه الان موجود هم يريدون ان
يتحقق العداله صحيح انهم حصلوا على
تعويضات بمليارات الدولارات عام 2003
عندما انهيت القضيه وكان هناك ايضا همم
تصريحات رسميه ان ذلك من قبل المسنين
الامريكيين وكان هناك مشروع في الكونغرس
الامريكي تقدم بها انا ذاك الرئيس
همم يتعهد بان كل املاك وممتلكات لهم
علاقه بقضيه الاقرب من الليبيين ستكون
محفوظه لهم ولكن الان بالنسبه لي ضحايا
وعائلات الضحايا الطائره هم يريدون تحقيق
العداله هذا ما نعرفه حتى الان في انتظار
المزيد من التفاصيل في الساعات اللاحقه
سنتابع الموضوع
اكيد مره اخرى انه عمل 2008 كان هناك
تاكيد من الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق ان بانه
لن يكون هناك اي متابعه او محاكمه جديده
ولكن من راى الان ان هناك محاكمه بعد
اعتقال
الولايات المتحده وقانون ايضا سنتابع معك
طبعا حسين همم فورا ورود اي شديد او
تفاصيل حول هذه القضيه شكرا لك مراسل
العربيه حسين الطود حدثنا من واشنطن من
امام المحكمه التي يحاكم بها الان همم ابو
عشيله من بن غازي ايضا للحديث عن الموضوع
ينضم الينا ابراهيم الدرسنا في البرلمان
الليبي استاذه ابراهيم يعني موقف البرلمان
الليبي كان واضح انتم تطالبون اليوم بفتح
تحقيق التعويل على النائب العام همم اليوم
الممكن يعني ان يصل الى نتيجه بهذا
التحقيق ومعرفه كيف تم تسليم ابو عيشه الى
الامريكيين
مسائك سعيد الحقيقه نحن نعول على الضمير
الشعبي في ليبيا يعول على الضمير
القومي والروح الوطنيه لدى سكان العاصمه
في طرابلس نعول على الروح الوطنيه لدى
الوزراء واعضاء الوزارات في في في هذه
الحكومه البائسه التي باعت كل شيء من اجل
ان تبقى على كرسي وسده الحكم السيد النائب
العام الصديق السور الرجل يعني يشتغل في
محيط يعني مخيف ومحيط يعني يعش بالمشاكل
ولكن دائما هو محرضا من المسؤولين سواء في
البرلمان او من الشعب الليبي ولكن الذي
يملكه السيد صديق السوء امام هذه الطغمه
الفاسده التي بعد كل شيء وتملك السلاح
ومتحالفه مع الميليشيات همم المؤدرجه
ان همم
وضعت كل المقدرات الدوله الليبيه تحت تحت
بالامس القريب راينا همم مليار دينار
ليبياشيات على اساس صرفت الداخليه
اليوم الحكومه لا تعترف بقرارات مجلس
النواب ولا بشرعيته همم هل يمكن ان تذهبوا
يعني الى قرار يلزم الحكومه باي شيء او ان
تضغط على الحكومه عبر النائب العام خصوصا
ان القانون الليبي يمنع تسليم المطلوبين
الى الخارج
سيدتي هذا الموضوع اشبعناها يعني شرحا لكن
انا لا استغرب من البيت بهذا الفعل
وحكومته لان الرجل بسبب البقاء في همم في
على الكرسي الحكم يفعل ما يشاء وهمم
ويستحل ما حرم همم من العهود والمواثيق
والثوابت الوطنيه لكن ما يدعو للدهشه هو
هذا التصرف من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي لم تحترم تعاهدات التي تعاهدت بها
امام المجتمع الدولي وامام الدول راس
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي دخلت في
ذلك الموقف وكان لها يعني بفضل الاكبر بعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى في حال هذه القضيه همم
هذا الاتفاق يعني مهر بتوقيع ال- ال-
الكونغرس الامريكي واصبح اتفاقا يعني همم
مضمونا بضامنه سواء من المجتمع الدولي ومن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يوم الرئاسه
الامريكيه ومن يكون جرس الامريكي من مجلس
النواب الامريكي بان لا يلاحق يده بعد ذلك
ثم ان الشعب الليبي سيدتي الكريمه دفع ثمن
من عام 92 الى 2006 الطيران مغلق الاموال
الليبيه مجمده الشعب الليبي عاش ضنا كان
من من في الحياه بسبب هذه القضيه ثم بعد
ذلك الشاعر المجتمع الليبي الحكومه
الليبيه انا ذلك دفعت اكثر من 10 مليار
دولار امريكي لاسر هذه
لهؤلاء الضحايا الان عند تحدث مراسلكم عن
ان هناك ارتياح لدى اسره يجوز يعني همم
الكلام بهذا الشكل هذا يدل على ان امريكا
لا تحترم وثيقه ولا تحترم العوده نحن يعني
نفتقد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لانها
لم تراعي همم الخصوصيه الليبيه الحاله
الليبيه يستغلت الضعف الليبي استغلت
التشهد الليبي همم هو في الحقيقه لكي يزين
السيد باين الذي خسر كل ال- ال-
الانتخابات النصفيه وهو يستعد الاسئله
شكرا لك استاذ ابراهيم في البرلمان اللي
بيحدثنا من بنغازي المشاهدين ساعود واياكم
الى هذه الصور مباشره من امام المحكمه في
واشنطن الكاميرا العربيه هناك طبعا كنا
تبعنا مع مراسل العربيه من هناك الصوره
ابو عجيله موجود الان داخل المحكمه وهو
يخضع للمحاكمه للتذكير بان هذا الملف اغلق
عام 2008 بمرسوم رئاسي امريكي وبالتوافق
بين الدولتين الا انه اعيد وفتح اليوم بعد
تسليم ابو عيشه ليلى وبعد خطفه على يد
جماعه داخل بنغازي وتسليمه للامريكيين
[موسيقى]
بعد فشل النظام الايراني على احتجاجات
الشعبيه في كافه انحاء ايران لجا النظام
الى ارهابي الشارع عبر التنفيذ الثانيه
على ارتباط بحركه الاحتجاجات وفقا ما
اعلنه موقع ميزان التابع للسلطه القضائيه
الايرانيه واكد الموقع ان مجيد رضا همم
اقدم علنا في مدينه مشهد في شمال شرقي
البلاد بعد ما اذينا بقتل عنصرين من القوى
الامنيه هذا وكاله سلطات الايرانيه قد
اعدمت محسن شكري 23 عاما الذي اذينا بتهمه
جرح عنصر من قوات البسيج وقطع الطريق في
بدايه الحركه الاحتجاجيه هذه الاعدامات
اثاره ردود فعل دوليه ومنظمات حقوقيه
وامنيه تحذر من ان الكثير من الايرانيين
معرضون لخطر الاعدام الوشيك القضاء
الايراني اعلن ادانت احد عشر شخصا
بالاعدام حتى الان على خلفيات الاحتجاجات
لكن النشاط يقولون ان نحو 12 شخصا اخرين
يواجهون تها من قد تؤدي الى انزال عقوبه
الاعدام في حقهم حتى الساعه السلطات
الايرانيه اوقفت على خلفيه الاحتجاجات ما
لا يقل عن 14,000 شخص وفق الامم المتحده
اظهرها شريط فيديو مصور والده الشاب
الايراني مجيد رضا وهو وهي تبكي بعد اعدام
ابنها وهي تهتف ضد خامنئي وتصفه بالقاتل
وتقول ان حكمه باطل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا هو حكم على شقيقين كرديين من مدينه من
مدينه بمحافظه اذربيجان الغربيه في ايران
بالاعدام بعد مشاركتهما في الاحتجاجات
وحسب منظمه هنا لحقوق الانسان فان محكمه
في مدينه بعاصمه اذربيجان الغربيه حكمت
على فرحات طه زادا
وفرزاد طه زاده بالاعدام وصدر الحكم في
المحكمه غيابيا دون حضور المتهمين واعتقل
فرزات طه زاد في الخامس والعشرين سبتمبر
في معتقل شقيقه في التاسعه عشر من نوفمبر
وظلت اخبار اعتقالهما وحكم الاعدام طي
الكتمان حتى اليوم
ماما
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه
بعد اعدام ثاني المحتجين بايران مجيد رضا
في اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع من اعتقاله وقال
المجلس في بيان له ان اعدام مسجد رضا ينظر
بالخطر على حياه بقيه المحتاجين المحكومين
بالاعدام واضاف المجلس ان استخدام عقوبه
الاعدام ضد المحتاجين لا يتوافق مع الحق
في الحياه
بابا بابا
الايراني
قمع السلطات الايرانيه المنهج واستخدامها
القوه المفرطه ضد المحتاجين داعيا السلطات
الايرانيه الى وقف الاعتقالات العشوائيه
المعارضه الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا تنفيذ
ايران عقوبه الاعدام بحق المحتاجين مطالبا
باجراء تحقيقات مستقله حول حمله
للسلاح النووي كما نددت وزيره خارجيه
الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهديكم
اذا هذه الصور من جزيره قشم حيث قام
المحتاجين بحرق صوره
معنا من لندن عارف نصر الباحث في الشهاده
الايراني استاذ عارف يعني اليوم استخدام
كوسيله لايقاف المظاهرات ولترهيب الشعب
الايراني والعقوبات التي صدرت من المجتمع
الدولي اليست متاخره خصوصا انه ما قبل
العقوبات معروف ان النظام الايراني حسب
المنظمات الحقوقيه يمارس اكبر عدد يعني
اعدام نسبه لعدد السكان
تحيه طيبه لك يا استاذه ليال والمشاهديه
العربيه الكرام الواقع دعيني قبل ان يجيب
على هذا السؤال ان اشرح نقطه مهمه جدا وهي
ان عمليه الاعدام ايضا في المغاربه التي
يعتمدها النظام الايراني فيما يبدو بانها
تفيد بعده قضايا بمعنى انها بدات اولا من
خلال الاغتيال المباشر وخاصه في الجمعه
السوداء في زاهدان وفشلت همم اعتمدت على
الاختيالات الغامضه وربما عمليه ادعاء ان
هنالك انتحار الى همم الى هؤلاء المعتقلين
الذين انتحروا بظروف غامضه وفشلوا برجع
المتظاهرين النقطه الثالثه قامت بارسال
بعض المتطرفين والدعوه بانهم ينتظموا
ينتمون الى تنظيم داعش وفشلت برجع
المتظاهرين لذلك انا اعتقد بان عمليه
الاعدام هي ضمن هذا الحلقات التي فشلت
برجع المتظاهرين و الان تعد تعدم
المتظاهرين بتهمه الحرام او بتهمه القصاص
وبافتره وجيزه ودون حتى محامين ذلك هذا ان
دل على شيء يدل بان النظام الايراني يخشى
كثيرا حجم هذه همم
ربما الحراك الثوري هذه نقطه والنقطه
الثانيه سريعا اعتقد بانها تفيد بان ربما
جانب العسكري لا يوافق رؤيه الايراني
بالدخول وغمع حديث الاحتجاج يعني الاستاذ
عارف من المعروف ان ما حكم الاعدام
بالنظام الايراني هو اعلى همم درجات
العقاب او الدرجات المحاسبه اليوم يعني
اذا ما قرانا بالمسببات للاعدام هناك
مسببات كثيره منها قلب النظام منها يعني
بسببات كثيره وكبيره وليست التظاهر ان نحن
نتحدث عن تظاهر عن قصه لجوء النظام الى
اقصى درجه العقاب اليس تعبير عن اثمته
الحقيقيه اليوم
الفعل هذا كما امم تفضلت بانه يعبر ايضا
ليس فقط عن الازمه بل عن الخشيه الكبيره
جدا وربما التخبط على الصعيد السياسي وعلى
الصعيد العسكري واداره هذه الازمه همم
ربما عده قراءات ممكن ايضا همم ننظرها من
خلال هذه الاعدامات من خلال الجغرافيا
التي تنبها الاعدام وهي مدينه مشهد همم
حاضر ربما المدينه التي ينتمي اليها
المرشد الايراني وكذلك ابراهيم رئيسي
ومدينه طهران لذلك احتفظ بان حتى جغرافيه
ربما جغرافيا هذه الاعدامات ايضا تشير بان
النظام الايراني يعتمد بان تبغى العمره
الفارسي يبغى موالي الى النظام الايراني
وربما سالبه التي استخدمها مع المناطق
الشعوب يكون ربما بطريقه اكثر وحشيه ولا
تعتمد على فقط الاعدامات بل تع ربما على
الاغتيالات الغامضه كما شاهدنا في زاهدان
او ما شاهدناه في الاهواز او كردستان شكرا
لك يا استاذ عارف نصر حدثتنا من لندن
مشاهدينا اعود واتابع واياكم الصور
المتداوله لحرق محتاجين لصور من ايه في
جزيره قشم الايرانيه قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
اصابات في اشتباك المسلح بين الجيشين
الصيني والهندي على الحدود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت وزيره الدفاع
الفرنسيه السابقه ميشيل اليوم ماغي في
برنامج الذاكره السياسيه الذي سيتم بث
حلقاته في وقت لاحق على شاشه العربيه ان
شخصيات من النظام السوري متورطه في جريمه
اغتيال رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه الاسبق
رفيق الحريري وان المحكمه الدوليه الخاصه
بلبنان تعرضت لضغوط كبيره لتبديل قرارها
النهائي وحصر الجرائم بعناصر من الاشياء
حزب الله وللتنويه مشاهدينا ستبث هذه
الحلقه في وقت لاحق عبر برنامج الذاكره
السياسيه مع زميل طاهر بركه
لقيت سميد
وانت تحملين الاثنين او كما اعتقدت
القياده الفرنسيه
ولكن لماذا
حقيقي
عايزه
هذا سؤال تحديدا من اراد ان يحمي النظام
السوري القيادات على الاقل التي
اذا النظام السوري
لكي تشطب اسماء بعض قياداتها المتورطه
كلمه مصري فيديو
سمعت هذه المقابله يعني الضغط
على الجهات الدوليه لكي لا تشمل بهذه
القرارات قالت بان النظام نفسه كيف يمكن
النظام نفسه ان يقبل بالضغوطات خصوصا ان
المحكمه بدات بعد الاغتيال وانتهت يعني
قبل سنتين وكان النظام بوضع حارش
المشكله ليست في النظام السوري الذي يمارس
الضغوط بطبيعه الحال النظام السوري يمارس
الضغوط ايران وحزب الله مارسوا الضغوط
ولكن السؤال المجتمع الدولي الذي رعى هذه
المحكمه والذي اسس هذه المحكمه كيف يقبل
بالرجوع لهذه الضغوط المشكله هنا من هو
النظام الغربي سواء كان فرنسي او امريكي
او اي نظام اخر الذي قبل بهذه الضغوط
والتي ردح لهذه الضغوط والذي على الاقل
وفقا لمقالته الوزير الفرنسيه السابقه
يعرف بهذه الضغوط وقبل بها وسكت عنها ولم
يتحرك في مجلس الامن الدولي
من جديد
عمليا مصداقيه المحكمه الدوليه بهذه
الطريقه لم تضرب على العكس المحكمه
الدوليه وفقا للمواد التي حصلت عليها
اصدرت حكما بايدان عناصر من حزب الله
وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون نظام المحكمه لا
ينص على محاكمه اطار او كيان سياسي او
حزبي ولكن عمليا الادانه بالمفهوم السياسي
والادانه بالمفهوم يعني بالنتيجه السياسيه
معروفه ان هذه حزب الله وحزب الله يعترف
الان وال- اا عمليا وهو يتصرف بانه حليف
للنظام السوري اا لا اعتقد ان المحكمه
فقدت مصداقيتها الذي فقد مصداقيته
والمجتمع الدولي الذي يعرف ان هناك
بشخص القانوني
المجتمع الدولي هو الذي فقد المصداقيته
الان وهو نتيجه الكلام التي الذي قالته
الوزير الفرنسيه واضح ان الانظمه السياسيه
امرت على المحكمه الدوليه وان كان لديها
اا اا عمليا مسيرين مختلفين ما صار علني
يدعي انه يريد البحث عن الحقيقه واحقاق
العداله ومسار فعل من تحت الطويله هو اا
عمليا يقيم الصفقات مع نظام بشار الاسد
كما انه يقيم الان او يحاول الان ان يقيم
الصفقات مع النظام الايراني مع النظام
حافظ الاسد على حساب الشعب السوري والشعب
اللبناني وايضا مع النظام الايراني الان
على حساب الشعب اللبناني والشعب السوري
وكل الشعوب التي تتعرض
للاحتلال يعني
هذا يعني هذه الجهات او هذا النظام الذي
تتحدث عنه اليوم يحاول اعاده منذ فتره
يعني ليس اليوم فقط اعاده سوريا الى
المنظومه الدوليه
والمنظومه الفاعله واعطاء شيء من الشرعيه
على حساب طبعا الشعب السوري وكل من تهجر
من سوريا هذا كله بهذا التوقيت واعاده فتح
هذا الملف اليوم ماذا يعني بالسياسه
بالقانون الدولي
وبكل ردود الفعل التي ممكن ان تظهر عنها
القانون الدولي بكل اسف في هذه المرحله
كما في مراحل سابقه لا يزال خاضعا للمصالح
الدوليه وليزات
للصفقات التي تجري من تحت الطاوله على
حساب الشعور
بكل اسف هذا هو الواقع هذا هو الواقع يعني
همم ما يدمي القلب اكثر في هذه المرحله هو
ان وزيره فرنسيه سابقه تقول هذا الكلام
ولا تقول فضيحه في فرنسا وفي غير فرنسا
همم له مطالبه القاده السياسيين في
المرحله التي مورثت فيها الضغوطات همم
بتوضيح همم ما جرى ولتحميل المسؤوليه
السياسيه امام الراي العام وامام همم امام
الراي العام المحلي سواء كان في الغرب او
الراي العام الدولي في كل في كل دول
العالم همم اعتقد انه المسائله في هذه في
هذا المجال يجب ان تنطلق يعني لا اقول انه
نعم في هذه المرحله يجب ان يتحرك لبنان
همم فاقد
للسياده وفاقد للقرار ولكن اعتقد انه همم
مصداقيه الراي العام مستقيه الانظمه
الدوليه سقطت في هذه المرحله همم يعني
نتيجه لهذا الكلام كما انها تسقط في كل
شكرا
من اجل السياده
[موسيقى]
الان مفتاح الجنوب للجيش الاخراني فقط
الدفاع الروسي قد ينهار بعد القصف الذي
طال المدينه الاسراتيجيه التي تسيطر عليها
موسكو منذ فبراير الماضي هذه المدينه
الاستراتيجيه ينظر اليها على انها الهدف
الرئيسي التالي للقوات الاوكرانيه وفي
جنوب البلاد منذ ان السعاده مدينه خيرسون
الرئيسيه وفقا لصحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه
القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل الان على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر نيبرو مقابل حيث اصبحت قادره
على وضع انظمه على الضفه الغربيه التي
لعبت دورا محوريه في هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد
في الجنوب والشرق الاوكراني موضع طبعا
القوات الروسيه في المدينه تحت تهديد وفقا
لجارتيان وفي حال سقطت ميليتو بول فان خط
الدفاع الروسي باكمله سين على طول الطريق
الى خرصون طبعا وقد تكتسب القوات
الاوكرانيه طريقه مباشره الى شبه جزيره
القرم كما نتابع هنا هذا الامر طبعا قد
يسهم بان تربح اكياف الحرب ولكن الكلفه
ستكون باهظه جدا على الغرب لان اكياس تطلب
خمسه مليارات دولار شهريا تقول صحيفه وصفت
جورنال لانه في حال اصبحت الحرب نزاعا
مجمدا مع استمرار القتال في بعض المناطق
هذا يعني ان الاقتصاد الاوكراني لن يتعافى
وسيؤدي الى مزيد من الازمات الانسانيه
ويتطلب طبعا دعاما ماليا دوليا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وكاله الانباء الهنديه عن وقوع
اشتباكات مسلحه بين القوات الحدوديه
الهنديه والصينيه في ولايه ارونا تشال
براداش الهنديه وبحسب الوكاله فان قوات
صينيه تجاوزت منطقه حدوديه وتم صدها فيما
اصيب عدد من العسكريين من الجانبين بجروح
طفيفه وانسحب الجانبان على الفور من منطقه
وتعاد هذه الحادثه الاولى من نوعها منذ
الشباك مايو عام 2020 عندما قتل 20 جنديا
هنديا واصيب عدد اخر في اشتباكات عنيفه مع
القوات الصينيه في منطقه لا داخل الجبليه
على الحدود بين البنات
نبقى في اسيا ايضا وننتقل من الهند والصين
الى افغانستان حيث اعلنت حكومه طالبان
مقتل ثلاثه مسلحين اطلقوا النار في فندق
بالعاصمه كابول وقالت حكومه طالبان
افغانستان في بيان انه لا يوجد قتله في
صفوف الاجانب المقيمين بالفندق الذي يرتده
عاده رجال اعمال
مراسل العربيه ان الفندق الذي شهد الهجوم
يقع قرب القصر الرئاسي وما قرات البعثات
الديبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
في بريطانيا تحضيرات من طقس قاسم وثلوج
وامطار ومطار هيثرو يلغي عشرات الرحلات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت اسرائيل عن الرساله
الاخيره لجاسوسها اليكوين قبل اعتقاله في
دمشق عام 1965 ونقل الرساله معلومات بشان
اجتماع بين الرئيس السوري انذاك حافظ امين
الحافظ بهيئه الاركان السوريه وبشاركه
كبار الضباط وقال رئيس الوساد ان كوهين
اعتقل بعدما تمكنت دمشق من تعقب احدى
رسائله
تحاولوا من الصوت وتر لتواصل الاجتماعي
مره اخرى اطلاق خدمتها المميزه لعلامه
الزرقاء بعد شهر من فشل محاوله سابقه وقال
تويتر انها ستسمح للمستخدمين بشراء
الشركات في خدمات بلوتوث تويتر للحصول على
علامه اختيار زرقاء والوصول الى ميزات
خاصه اعتبارا من اليوم الاثنين تم منح
علامه الاختيار الزرقاء في الاصل للشركات
والمشاهير والهيئات الحكوميه والصحفيين
الذين تم التحقق منهم بواسطه المنصه مقابل
ثمانيه الدولارات شهريه
على مكان زرقوان بدل من علامات واحده منصه
تنبر تطرح اعلان جديد منافس وفاخر من
التويتر العلامتين الزرقاء
للمقابل
7.99 دولار لمره واحده فقط بدا اعلان
للمنافسه مع تويتر خصوصا لاعاده باعاده
بقوه الى ساحه الفضاء الالكترونيه منذ
استحواذ الهم ماسك على تويتر والتي صاحبها
مشاكل كثيره وجها ماسك وشركته الجديده
وبدا بدات تنمر اعلانيه جديده لتشجيع
المستخدمين على العوده الى المنصه التي
كانت شائعه عام 2007 حين اسس ديفيد كارت
هذه المنصه الذي اشتهر بطبيعته الساخره
والاكثر فوضويه من تويتر الرئيس التنفيذيه
الحالي لهذه المنصه همم كشف ان الموقع
يعمل الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى وان النشاط
عليه فاق التوقعات كما ان تحميل التطبيق
ارتفع الى ثمانيه وخمسين بالمئه على اجهزه
ابل و 57% على اجهزه اندرويد خلال نوفمبر
الماضي وانا اكثر من 18 مليون مستخدم زار
الموقع خلال اكتوبر شركه ياهو كانت اشتركت
عامه واشترت عام 2013 هذه المنصه باكثر من
مليار دولار وبلغ عدد المدونات على المنصه
اكثر من 200 و15 مليون مدونه حيث يستطيع
المستخدم انشاء اكثر من مدونه عام 2014
[موسيقى]
من دبي ينضم الينا فريد كريم مختص في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي فريد يعني
بالسابق عندما كنا نقارن ال التطبيقين كنا
نتحدث عن فجوه هائله او فجوه هائله بين
التطبيقين ان كان من عدد الكلمات ان كان
من الفيديوهات وغيرها اليوم مع التعديلات
التي
قرر الى ماسك ادخال الى تويتر هل مازلنا
نتحدث عن اختلاف كبير بين الموقعين او
منصتين
الاخلاق
للمستخدمين المختلفين النصب تمبلر بتعتمد
على المحتوى الطويل وهمم تويتر بتعتمد على
المحتوى المكتوب القصير جدا وبيناسب طبيعه
المستخدمين ان هم يعبروا عن افكارهم همم
بطريقه
نقدر نقول مختصر جدا وهمم
الهدف او الرساله اللي بيحاول يرسلوها
بشكل مباشر على العكس تماما على تن- اا
الواحد يقدر يتكلم براحته ويكتب موضوع
طويل جدا الاختلاف كبير بمناسبه
الاحصائيات لسه كنت باقرا يعني اكثر ما
بين تقريبا همم 10 ملايين مستخدم على
تويتر
همم
تويتر همم
وغيرهم ان هم بيبينوا ان بعضهم من سياسه
الى ماسك ورغبتهم في فرق المناصه تقريبا
اقل من 2% بس من اجمالي المشتركين هم اللي
اخذوا القرار بمسح حساباتهم ومغادر
التويتر بلا عوده
جماعيه
معظم الحصه السوقيه لتويتر مبالغ فيه هنا
وعما
حتى لحظه ما ما فيش اي احصائيات بتدل على
ان في نزوح جماعه او هجره جماعيه من موقع
تويتر ولكن في دعوات
مختلفه من افراد مختلفه لمغادره تويتر
الذهاب الى المنصات اخرى غير همم
ولكن حتى اللحظه ما نقدرش نقول ان في نجاح
ملحوظ للدعوات المختلفه همم
يعني ما هو كان معلوم عن هذه المنصه بان
يعني ثقافه الغضب الهستيريه لا رقابه يعني
هي متفلقه اكثر اكثر نوعا ما من تويتر هل
هذا سيدفع الناس الى الذهاب الى هذه
المنصه ام انها ستكون نقطه الضعف لان يعني
تويتر بدوابطه الاخلاقيه وحتى وان كان
ماسك سيعدل نوعا ما الى انها مازال تحافظ
عليها
الى مصر ينتقل بشكل رئيسي
اتجاهه او ما يصفوه باتجاه الفوضى وهنا
على عكس
الدعوات
المؤهضه الاتجاه الى مصر الفضوي وهم بيذهب
الى المنصه اكثر فوضويه فالموضوع غريب جدا
ما همم مش شايف له اي نجاح بصراحه ولكن
الايام اللي هتوريها في مشاكل كثير
متزامنه مع استحواذ الى مصر ولكن اعتقد ان
المشاكل طبيعيه في مرحله انتقاليه
لانتقال الاداره من الملك السابق للمالك
الحالي
وخلينا نشوف التطورات هتوصل ايه
شكرا لك يا فريد كريم مختص في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي حدثنا من دبي على ما
يبدو موقع حديث تويتر سيبقى طيله الفتره
المقبله شكرا لك عليه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار المونديال تقام يوم غد الثلاثاء
المباراه الاولى من الدوري النصف النهائي
بمباراه الارجنتين وكرواتيا بعد مفاجاه
الاخيره باقصاء المنتخب البرازيلي احد
المرشحين للفوز باللقب وفوز الارجنتين على
هولندا ليتقابل في نصف النهائي الاول في
البطوله وفي اليوم الثاني من مباريات
الدوري نصف النهائي يتقابل المنتخب
المغربي اسود الاطلس مع فرنسا والتي ستقام
يوم الاربعاء هذا وقابل مراسل العربيه في
المغرب مجموعه من اصدقاء وجيران النجم
المغربيه يوسف النصيري في الحي الذي نشا
فيه بمدينه فاس فن تابع
نصيري لاعب كبير اييه مرضيه الوالدين
الهداف تاريخي ديال الفريق الوطني
هداف تاريخي ديال جوجكوؤوس العالم 2018 و
2022 ااا ولد حي شعبي
في الحومه
والحمد لله قدر العلميه
بالنسبه اليوسف الناصري ماشي ماشي صاحبي
ولا ولد
[موسيقى]
مع امه العزيزه معمول
بالنسبه ليوسف الناصيري هو واحد الفخر
المدينه المنتخب
المغرب
[موسيقى]
تسبب السقوط الكثيف لثلوج في اجزاء من
بريطانيا ببعض الاضطرابات في مطارات
وخدمات القطار كارينا كامل وتفاصيل من
هناك
مشاهد جميله هنا في لندن وحول المملكه
المتحده بعد سقوط كثيف الثلوج خلال ال 24
ساعه الاخيره ولكن صاحبت معها اضطرابات
شديده لحركه النقل والعمل في البلاد
عده مطارات من بينها مانشستر الغت العديد
من الرحلات ومطارات هيثرى وجع تويك اعلنت
عن تاخير او تاجيل العشرات من الرحلات
خدمه القطارات ايضا المتوقفه في انحاء
عديده من البلاد وهنا في لندن مترو
الانفاق يشهد تعطيلا شديدا اغلب الخطوط
فيها تعليق الخدمه او اغلاق تام لبعض
المحطات وفي الوقت نفسه اصدر الشبكه
الوطنيه البريطانيه بلاغا لتهيئتي مصنعه
فحم الشتويين ضمن خطه طوارئ ان لطمئنه
الناس بشان امدادات الطاقه
من نقص شديد في امدادات الكهرباء من دون
ان تؤكد ما اذا كانت البلاد ستحتاج اليهما
كما تسبب ثلج في بعض الحوادث من بينها حدث
سقوط اربعه اطفال في بحيره جليد في منطقه
برمنجهام مساء الاربعاء وفي وقت لاحقا
اكدت الشرطه ان تلاته من الاطفال فرغوا
الحياه فيما بقى الرابع في حاله حرجه
وستحذيرات من السلطات بتوخي الحذر مع
استمرار موجه البرد لبدعه ايام كارينا
كامل العربيه لندن
بصناعه قنبله واشنطن يعيد التصعيد ضد
حكومه
البرلمان يصف الخطوه بالخيانه
الاعدامات سال الامم المتحده تحذر من ان
حياه المحتاجين في خطر وعقوبات اوروبيه
تطالب مسؤولين وكيانات ايرانيه
وزيره الدفاع فرنسيه سابقه للعربيه نظام
الاسد متورط باغتيال الحريري والمحكمه
الدوليه بدلت قرارها تحت ضغط
بشعار مشابه وعلامتين زرقاوين بدل واحده
منصه تسخر من تويتر وتستقبل المهاجرين
منها
[موسيقى]
التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره
كما كل ليله الان مشاهدينا الى 360 مع
الزميله راويه راويه اليك ماذا لديك
الليله اهلا بك ليال سنتحدث عن اعدام ثاني
متظاهر ايراني اليوم بالاضافه الى تصريحات
خاصه لوزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه السابقه حول
العراق والعديد من الملفات